[Music]
hello
foreign
[Music]
blue
[Applause]
[Music]
so
with a laptop or some sort of
video camera and everything like that so
it's interesting to see it look into
people's faces
um thankfully we do have people who are
meeting with us online
so welcome to you guys as well um so if
you
wouldn't mind get it take a moment uh
find a seat uh
when you get there you're welcome to
take off a mask if you need to
or you're welcome to leave that on
however you feel comfortable
for those of you don't know me my name
is don jacobs
i'm just one of the leadership team
members here at the table
we're thrilled that you are here um
especially since this
is our one of our very first especially
um in this transitional period being
able to see each other face to face so
this is
amazing um to be able to see everyone
we are actually going to be resuming in
person
um absolutely in-person
services next week so we're super
excited about that that's going to be
a breath of fresh air it's been awesome
awesome looking forward to that
uh just one quick announcement i do want
to just let people know
um so since we are going to be meeting
next week
in person we are going to actually uh be
going to have
like a a close clothing drive
so um which is perfect because i've been
actually going through my closet and i
have a
pile of stuff that has got to be taken
care of
so um if you're kind of in that
situation as well
most definitely take your bring your
gently used clothes and things of that
nature
bring it to the church next week with
you as well so as we're meeting in
person
we're going can be able to drop it off
um
and as we transition into our worship
time i'm just going to quickly uh just
leave this in a quick prayer
lord thank you so much for just allowing
us to be
together this is our first easter
together as a church in person
and we are thankful for that we are
thankful and blessed
uh that we are able to get together to
meet
um to be able to have this time just to
remember
you to remember your son to remember
all the things that were the many
blessings that we have on this easter
sunday
open up our hearts and our minds so that
we can
connect with you in christ and i pray
amen
[Music]
test cool
when something is empty there is lack
empty tank empty
emptiness means disappointment loss
pain anxiety heartache accept
except when it doesn't the tomb is empty
see the place where they laid him he is
not here
he is risen
[Music]
huh
oh
this is not
[Music]
this is not our last this
is not our last breath
we will open our house
oh
[Music]
and you know you'll be
all right
this is not the end this
we is shine like the stars
[Applause]
[Music]
in luke 24 on the first day of the week
very early in the morning the women took
spices they had prepared and went to the
tomb
they found the stone rolled away from
the tomb but when they entered
they did not find the body of their lord
while they were wondering about this
suddenly two men
clothed in cloaks that gleamed like
lightning stood beside them
in their fright the women bowed down
with their faces to the ground
but the men said to them why do you look
for the living among the dead
he is not here he has risen
[Music]
jesus you're the one who
saves us constantly
creates us into
something new
jesus surely you will find
[Music]
all things news in jesus
jesus you're the one who saves
us constantly creates us
into something new
jesus surely you will find
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll make all
[Music]
we'll things all these things
we'll make all things new
just one touch
and everything changes
everything changes
with one word
[Music]
the world rearranges
worldly arranges
death was defeated
this woman
is paid
jesus
this one
healer and savior my healer
and savior oh
there's none
the like maker you're the miracle-maker
i want jesus
[Applause]
there's no one like you there's no one
like you
nothing and no one compares to you god
there's no one like you there's no one
like you
there's no one like you nothing
is
there's no one like you there's no one
like you
[Music]
just one touch
and everything changes
everything changes
jesus
[Music]
you were the lord
a razor hallelujah
in the presence of my enemies
i raise a hallelujah
than the unbelief
my weapon is a melody
i raise a hallelujah
heaven comes to fight for me
hope will arise death is defeated
the king is alive
i'll raise a hallelujah
[Applause]
with everything inside of me
i'll raise the hallelujah
i will watch the darkness
me
is
death is defeated the king is alive
[Music]
sing a little louder
than the unbelief
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
i'm gonna sing in the middle of the
storm
louder and louder
[Music]
middle of is storm louder and louder
you're gonna hear my praises roar
up from the ashes
[Applause]
[Music]
hallelujah
yes god this morning we celebrate the
life that you've given us
we celebrate the opportunity to come
together
and claim that the love of god is
stronger than death
that your love is stronger than judgment
that each one of us are accepted and
loved by you
regardless of our past regardless of our
future
you say that we're yours
thank you so much for the hope that we
find inside of easter
and thank you for this time together we
celebrate you today
amen
amen can y'all give it up for the
team
thanks y'all and um
echoing what mindy said i am so stinking
grateful to not be talking to a screen
it is wonderful so happy easter it's
it's great to be with all of you
and um man it just brings me so much joy
to see a lot of faces that it's been a
while
and and also some new faces which is uh
wonderful as well
thank you if you are new here with us um
you know this is um it's been such an
insane year
that i i thought the the title of my
message this morning
is a fresh start a fresh start and
um i know we're still you know the
pandemic kind of continues to go on so
we're still kind of
recovering but it doesn't mean even the
fact that we're here now
um does feel like a fresh start in in
some way you know it's like
maybe it's not over we can kind of see
you know the dawn is rising you know
it's happening it's sort of like it's
often
as it's coming and um and i think that's
that's so beautiful and encouraging
and so um i wanted to i'm kind of
just unpack that a little bit this
morning don't worry so i practiced this
message
last night and it took me about an hour
and a half so don't worry i'm going to
tighten it i'm joking
uh don't worry it's not going to be an
hour and a half it'll be much shorter
but um but i do i want to read from
it's going to be second corinthians is
our our text this morning this is 2nd
corinthians chapter 5 verses 16 through
and this is a passage from the apostle
paul
and although i'm going to be reading it
from the message paraphrase
version so it might be a little
different than you read on your phone or
in your bible
but paul writes this he says we don't
evaluate people
by what they have or how they look
we looked at the messiah jesus that way
once and got it all wrong
as you know we certainly don't look at
him that way anymore
now we look inside and what we see
is that anyone united with jesus gets
a fresh start
is created new the old life
has gone and a new life emerges
isn't that beautiful the old life has
gone
and a new life emerges
a fresh start i think um i think you
know in big ways in small ways we all
need that fresh start
sometimes so it is of course uh it's
springtime
and it's uh because that you know
you might has anyone done any spring
cleaning anyone started like a little i
was talking with don
or don is he's over here he did a little
he did he did some spring cleaning
uh so a few of you might have you know
started to get on that now
now what if what of course what's the
idea of spring clean well basically over
time
uh specifically over the you know fall
and winter it's like people keep coming
into the house
and when they oh sweetie you okay there
got it
how am i connected to this mic you got
it all right she's good don't worry
she's good um so so the idea of spring
cleaning you know like people keep
coming into the house
and uh they keep bringing junk in with
them isn't this strange like
everyone knows like when they go to move
and you just realize like
oh my gosh how how where did all of this
come from
and this is what happens people come
into the house every day and you keep
bringing things in correct
and eventually at first you're sort of
trying to find you know new places
for it like you're stuffing it in the
drawers or you're arranging the junk
into neat
tidy piles and you want to do this
strategy where it's like i cleaned up
if it's sort of orderly piles
that was uh that's me um in my cleaning
it's like yeah i just arrange all right
but eventually the the piles it's like
okay
you've just eventually you've had enough
right it's like enough of a mental
beating
that you're like okay and i don't know
about you but i kind of just snap
where it's sort of a little bit
impulsive like
i go from oh it's okay we can work with
this too it's it's over
get it get it out get it all out we just
start clean i mean i literally will go
maggie and i will go to our kids room
and they're like old toys and like no i
love that we're like we have not seen
you play with that in
six months like uh-uh it's just all like
here here we go
like sometimes we will give them the
choice okay well it's either this
or this which one are you letting go of
right like because we just have to
eventually you just got to get it clean
so
and then what kind of happens you have
this moment where it's like the last bag
of trash
goes out to the dumpster or the last
bag of clothes for our clothing drive
next week don't forget next week
it goes to the car and you breathe that
sigh of relief
and it's like yes all is right with the
world now what just happened in that
moment
you had this this little snapshot this
little moment
of a fresh start
um one kind of covid esque phenomena
that really surprised me this year
was uh the whole housing market
i really if you asked me to predict like
what would happen
in this pandemic i thought i just i mean
i was legit worried like all my friends
in real estate i was like oh my gosh
this is going to be awful because you
know sinking economy
um even i thought people might be
hesitant you know just to go into others
houses
to like look around and it was like oh
no this is going to be so
i felt so bad um
but nope not at all like apparently
all of you moved i don't know what's
going on but like everyone the housing
market is absolutely
insane and i was like thinking like what
on earth
happened and i think this is what
happened that a year ago right about
this time
a year ago everyone was locked in their
house for like six
eight weeks whatever it was and they're
like oh my gosh
like i forgot that our house was this
small anyone have this experience of
just like you're in your house like oh
my god i can't take
this anymore and it's like we gotta
we gotta sell we gotta like we gotta do
something
about this and and apparently all of you
did and i must admit
like there is something beautiful about
i don't know what is it about selling
out like it's there's
or even changing apartments or whatever
you might have done like there's it's
kind of the
it's the change of scenery you know the
the physical change in space the new
location it's just like
yes what is that it's it's a fresh
start it's this sense of um we've got
something must change um
now i think of course reflecting back on
our passage that i read at the beginning
i think we can probably agree that um
when the apostle paul is talking about
in second corinthians this
um that basically through the the the
life the death and the resurrection of
jesus
that a fresh start is possible for all
of us
uh i think you'll agree uh that
that this is this is much more than the
small sense of relief we might get from
cleaning out our closet
or you know a little spark of joy that
happens for a while or maybe a week or
two when we you know change
locations and we move uh instead i think
i think you'll agree uh
that um what he's talking about is
something bigger
because those other kind of fresh starts
you probably
could agree that they're a little bit
superficial you know a little bit kind
of temp
a temporary fresh start you know
cleaning out your closet the drawers
it's nice
but eventually it gets junky again um
now
what's what this got me thinking like
what's what's the difference
um i think this is the difference like
why are those superficial
because the deeper more profound
fresh start is the one that happens
inside of us in other words
a fresh start in the truest deepest most
profound sense
is not so much about doing something new
like you know um
something just cool something like new
restaurant you know it's not so much
about
doing something new and a fresh start
isn't even
about necessarily going somewhere new at
least in the deepest most profound sense
uh whether it's a vacation or selling
the house a new house you know
um instead what is what is a fresh start
about in the deepest
truest most profound sense it's not
about doing something new and it's not
about
going somewhere new what is it about
it's about
becoming someone new
that's that's what a fresh start in it
in the deepest
sense is all about that's the fresh
start you and i need now
um what do i mean you know becoming
someone new that might sound a little
bit
you know grandiose or something um
basically what i'm thinking of
is uh the fact that we often have the
sense
that we cannot shake our past
[Music]
um that you might even use the word that
that we are haunted
by our past you know what do we mean by
haunted like when you think of a haunted
house it basically means
that something happened in the past at
that house
that some kind of essence some spirit
some vibe it's like
it's still with the home
right even uh even if we don't totally
know what that means exactly but there's
some sense of the past being here and i
think
in our own life um that same kind of
thing can happen to us that we
can be sort of haunted by our
past in other words we can be haunted
by by the scars not just of the body but
even of the mind
of an illness that we suffered a year or
five years or
ten years ago we can be haunted
by the relationships that did not
work out haunted by the abuse
that we suffered i mean it could have
even happened as a child it's like
30 40 50 60 years ago and it's like well
that was way back then
and yet in some sense it's like we're
still living with the residue
that we're haunted by that i'm haunted
by the doubts and the fears that that
just
on the inside that we do not have what
it takes haunted by unresolved conflict
haunted by anger and rage haunted by
by impulsive desires in the unhealthy
ways
that we cope with our life haunted
by past failures i think this is a big
one
because it's you know sometimes it's one
thing if something's been done to
us we can be haunted by that but at
least we still have the moral high
ground so to speak
you know i was a real victim there you
know it's it's
almost worse when like dang it i brought
it on myself
like i failed i messed up
and i can't go back to the best and like
change that fix it
like that's oh it's the worst um there's
a
somewhat difficult but a in many ways a
beautiful
uh story about one of the
one of jesus 12 disciples his name was
peter peter was
if you've read anything about him he was
what was peter like so he was one of the
not only one of the 12 disciples but he
was quite close to jesus um
definitely one of the kind of top three
like closest friends to christ
um he was also a bit kind of how would
you describe him kind of impulsive
he was there he was a big personality
very bold
peter was very bold he was the um he's
the kind of guy that metaphorically
speaking like
he had some he had he's either going to
hit a home run or he's going to
completely strike out like he's going
big
and because of this he had some
spectacular successes and some stun
i mean really painful failures one of
which you will
hear about in uh in just a moment um
so the story that i want to tell about
peter
this happened this was uh the night that
jesus
was betrayed you'll recall he had kind
of a jesus had a final meal
with his disciples and
uh during that that meal this is when
jesus famously kind of instituted
communion
uh the moment you know breaking the
bread and the wine and all that and this
is my body this is my blood
that moment some of you will recall that
um so this though this is a little
lesser known moment this is
after that so in the specific the gospel
of john jesus tells
uh this story or or we hear this story
about jesus and the disciples that
jesus is there they've had the kind of
communion moment they've had the meal
it's towards the end of the meal
when jesus drops this line he says he
looks at all 12 of the disciples
and he says um this very night
all of you will fall away from me
this is what he says all of you will
fall away from me i mean i'm wondering
imagine you're there
like how is that gonna land with you
all of you will fall away from me and
they're in all they're all silent except
two
peter yeah y'all weren't courageous
enough to like yell it out but i saw
many of you were going
peter peter yes you got it peter and now
and this is
this is what uh this is what peter says
okay this is what i like he says even if
i have to die
or no sorry you know in a second he says
his first line is
um i that that would never happen
and he says even it's funny he doesn't
say we would never do that
what he says is even if all of these
others fall away from you lord
he's very humble even if all of these
others fall away lord
i never will and this is when
jesus then famously goes on to predict
that who will that very night deny him
not once not twice but three times
here peter that was that was the bold
one yes
peter so this is he famously predicts
this then this is where peter then
follows up and says
no even if i have to die lord
i will never fall away okay so within a
few hours
jesus has arrested and
the disciples as he predicted they don't
really stand with him they
they all scatter they all flee
now peter is one of those that scatters
and flees but he
he is kind of trying to follow along
somewhat at a distance
so he's kind of tracking what's going on
so we're kind of in a town square right
now so you can imagine like if there was
um
maybe like the courthouse or something
just there that the bible says that
jesus or that
peter was literally kind of spending
time in a courtyard
you know kind of close enough like we
are that he can kind of maybe track at a
distance
where's jesus he's in the building okay
where they're going to take him next so
but not so close that he's you know
implicated with
now an accused criminal in christ all
right so he's kind of tracking at a
distance
when suddenly a servant girl
comes up to him and says oh my gosh
uh i recognize i recognize you you were
part of that
the group one of the the twelve that
were friends with g
you know jesus and what does peter say
but it's not the first time
it says i've never seen the man in my
life
he's the first then he moves he shifts
positions maybe
trying to kind of escape but he still
wants to track what's going on but he
needs to
get out of here where this person's
recognizing him so he moves he goes now
it says to uh some sort of gateway
and he's warming himself by a fire when
now a different servant girl
comes up to him and now for a second
time asks
wait you do you know jesus don't you and
what does peter say
now for the second time he denies it he
says
i i don't i don't know the man
that's his line i don't know the man
then a little while passes now a group
of people
come over to him and now they've really
got him because they say we've been
listening to you
speak you have a galilean accent that's
a region
uh sort of like here we would say people
are southern you know or something you
can tell like you're from the south
aren't you and so
he has this galilean accent which is the
type of accent jesus has he's also from
that region
he said we you were picking up you're
from that region like
you were with him we know it and the
bible says that peter
literally starts cursing and swearing
like he's now what does that say when
you get angry like that
what's going on inside peter i mean he's
terrified right because i mean it's easy
for us now
you know removed by 2 000 years to be
like oh what a what a bad guy
you know peter what a loser but i mean
this is serious stuff that's going on i
mean jesus is about to be crucified
this is really serious stuff so he's
hacked off he's afraid and he and he
says i swear
i've never met the man and right
then because remember jesus had said
before the rooster crows
you'll deny me three times and right
then what happens
the rooster cross and the bible says
that peter he's instantly it's like he
realizes you ever had that moment where
suddenly you like come to your senses
it's almost like a madness has overtaken
you you're operating in fear
you're operating in shame you know
whatever is going on
and then all of a sudden you snap and
that's kind of what happened that
rooster starts crowing
it's like all of a sudden he remembers
and it hits him
what he has done and the bible says that
he literally
ran out and he began to i mean he's a
grown man he starts to
weep bitterly he's peter is he's just
sobbing he's just sobbing wha what was
this
this was a moment of deep and profound
failure in peter's
life and presumably as far as peter's
concerned at this moment
this is the end of his story
at least him and jesus this is like this
is how it ends
he's just he's weeping bitterly and and
presumably he'll now be haunted by this
for
basically the rest of his life
so fast forward a few days and peter
a few the disciples they've gone back
to what they know best uh
fishing now that the kind of the
movement has ended they've heard kind of
you know rumors they've even had an
occasional appearance of like jesus kind
of
i've heard about the resurrected jesus
but you know the
the movement seems to be over so they go
back to what they know best what they
were before they were the disciples
traveling around with jesus they were
fishermen
and so they go back they're fishing
their fishing all night they don't catch
anything
when suddenly there's this man who's
standing
on the shoreline and he yells out to
them
he says this must have been very
annoying i imagine if you're a
professional fisherman
it's very annoying to have people give
you suggestions
on how to do it better you know so
basically this man
yells out to them try casting your nets
on the other side
of the boat i wonder how this hits them
they're just like
okay so maybe they're that desperate
apparently they were because they try it
they throw the nets on the other side of
the boat instantly i mean it's
absolutely full of fish it's bursting
it's about to burst
they haul the fish now the youngest
disciple is john the bible says
it's john who looks to the shore maybe
he has the best eyes i don't know he's
young
he looks and they're now it's also clear
that they're 100 yards offshore so it's
pretty far
and he looks out and he sees
and he can tell he says oh my gosh
it's jesus he turns to first person he
turns to
peter i don't know if he's trying to
warn peter i'm not sure what the dynamic
is here
but he says peter it is the lord
peter literally jumps out of the boat
no joke he jumps out of the boat now you
might be thinking oh my gosh is he
trying to escape
like jesus is back you know we all know
jesus says oh he's full of compassion
loving kindness but i mean if you're
peter wondering like
oh is it time to pay the piper but no
actually peter jumps out of the boat and
begins desperately
swimming towards the shore i think this
is one of the most beautiful images in
all of the bible
like peter this dignified disciple just
jumping out of a boat and all in his
clothes his robes you know
swimming for the shore
he finally gets there and jesus has
made a full little meal
of fish and bread and a little fire
going
and they sit there and they
eat breakfast together
the text doesn't say that they say
anything at this point
so they might just it might the whole
meal might just be in silence
they finish the meal and jesus
looks at peter and says
and asks for the first time peter
do you love me
and peter says yes lord
you know i do you know that i love you
and then jesus asks a second time
peter do you love me
and peter says yes lord you know
that i love you and then jesus asks
a third time peter
do you love me and what peter says is he
this time he adds
lord you know all things
you know that i love you
and i think it's so stunning because
jesus
asks him how many times three
times one time for every single one
of peter's failures three times
to restore peter
and i think he does this because jesus
knows
that peter loves him the question was
did peter still know that
it's interesting the the story actually
doesn't end there
because jesus then looks at peter
and says peter
then follow me
follow me as far as we know those are
the last words that the risen jesus
ever spoke to peter on this earth follow
me
and the reason i think it's significant
is if if you'll recall
three years earlier what were jesus
first words to
then fishermen soon to be disciple peter
do you remember what he said
follow me so i'll make you a fisher of
men
because he was a fisherman of course
follow
me and now three years later after
all of the failure after after
all of the betrayal jesus looks at peter
and says then follow me
his first words his last words follow
me now what was jesus offering
peter in that moment
a fresh start a fresh
start this this is what the cross and
resurrection of jesus
are all about that jesus on the cross
he he carries he bears all
all of our past all that haunts us
and then in the resurrection he says do
not
be afraid you do not have to be haunted
by your past anymore i think he says
that
in essence to peter and it echoes down
to the ages to us
you do not have to be haunted by your
past anymore
if you have lived in shame
then there is unconditional love and
acceptance
for you if you have sinned if you have
messed up
there is forgiveness for you
if you are hurting if you are in in pain
there is healing for you
this is what jesus is communicating us
he's saying i am the first
and the last i am the living one though
i was dead behold i am alive
forever more and what this means is that
a fresh start is available to each and
every
one of us it is possible for you and i
and and frankly with the year that we
have had
i'm just guessing my hunches
you need a fresh start i don't know if
it's if it's in your relationships a
fresh start in your
in your friendships in your marriage in
your in your
work um maybe just even in your own kind
of
spiritual psychological um the emotional
part of your soul
you know the inside part it's like i
just need a fresh
start and i think this is what god in
christ
wants to offer you today the possibility
of a new beginning of a fresh start
so if you will bow your heads and close
your eyes
[Music]
i want to name that you know maybe it's
been
a long time since you prayed or since
you felt close to god
but perhaps you came here feeling
quite haunted in some way maybe you can
sense that god is inviting you to a
fresh start
uh if that's you i'm not gonna you know
ask you to come forward anything what i
would like you to do
is just kind of open up your hands to
god just right there on your lap
just kind of open them up to god
and and what this is just a posture of
receiving something from him
and then i'm going to pray for you right
now
lord jesus thank you
that in your resurrection the old has
passed away
death has passed away despair has passed
away
and now a new life a new beginning
a fresh start is possible
i lift up my brothers and sisters here
who have felt
beat down discouraged
this year lord may 2021
may this moment may it be the beginning
of a year
where they turn to you in fresh ways
may resurrection life begin bursting
out of them may faith hope and love
be renewed in them and may they have the
fresh start
god that they need it's in the name
of the resurrected jesus that i pray
amen
[Music]
here comes a song
here comes a song and i say
it's all right
little darling it's been a long cold
lonely winter
little darling it feels like yes
it's it's been here
[Music]
it's all right
it feels like it's it's it's been
[Music]
here he goes
melting little darling
it seems like it's it's it's being here
here comes
here
[Music]
here comes the song
it's alright
it's all right
i'll be all right
and you know you'll be
all right
cause this is not the end
this is not the end of us
we will open our eyes
[Music]
happy easter you guys i think dawn's
gonna close us out
all right so thank you so much for uh
joining this this morning
um a couple of things um if you guys
have noticed that there are some plants
up here
uh this is actually a gift um from the
table family to your family
it's a gift that is expected to as brett
mentioned to uh as a symbol of a new
life
in jesus so just take take one of these
as one to your family
just as a reminder of today and then
i've got a couple of
other things um to kind of go over with
you one
don't forget about the um the clothing
drive that we mentioned since we're
gonna be meeting in person
next week um so i'm really excited we
keep saying that over and over we're
meeting in person
next week it's awesome so make sure if
you have something that you're cleaning
out your closets or anything like that
you want to bring that to church with
you next week we'll be happy to take
those donations
um a couple of other things um let's see
brittany can you raise your hand where
are you girl
i saw you for a whole second and then
there she is okay
so brittany is for those of you who are
new to us
um is our children's director and she
has got this amazing
easter egg hub set up for your families
so i'm going to give you a quick couple
of directions since i'm the one with
their microphone
so if you're in the end there's cones
that are lined up
for your kids if you have ages of
preschool and
under um those are for your kids to do
easter egg hunts
um and if you have kids that are older
than preschool then they can
participate on the outside of those
cones but when we get done with
announcements and things like that if
you wouldn't mind
lining up around the concrete and she'll
give you further directions on when to
get started and things of that nature
dad do a good job brittany did it okay
awesome awesome awesome okay
and then as we do a quick dispensary i
just want to launch you
into um the rest of your day with this
benediction so as you go into
god's world this week um be easter
to people be those who say why don't you
look at the living
among the dead jesus is not here
he is risen be ready to be surprised
with what god will do with you next
look for the risen christ and those that
you
meet let the holy spirit nudge you and
guide you
the tomb is empty because jesus is in
um as out in the world and now we must
go out into the world too
may the joy and wonder of that first
easter morning
live in your hearts today and every day
[Music]
amen
so it would have been nice to practice
that left
[Laughter]
[Music]
dad
you